our backyard podcast session
welcome back guys 2022
yeah uh new year new you that's what
they say that's what they've been saying
yeah that's what they've been saying
i've got a fresh corona light right here
actually it's a corona extra
extra light wow living the premium life
with salt and lime man
salty beer
[Music]
yeah when did that happen
i don't know man
maybe they just started doing it in
advertisements and then people were like
yeah of course you put salt in mexican
lager it's great
yeah
jake you have like the newest generation
of the mocap design on on right now
yeah so i'm actually
testing this
we haven't agreed to manufacture this
yet because personally i think maybe the
mo-cap pattern's a little too bright
against the yellow but
sam said it was striking so
what are your thoughts
i'm more of an understated black and
gray guy myself so i'm a fan of this
original design
but you know for everybody else out
there who wants to be a little more seen
than
that hint of yellow is very tasteful
it's just we have to be kind of precise
because the the these sweatshirts are
really expensive to manufacture because
it's
you know
we're we're printing it
um
well let's let's let's maybe we'll do an
instagram poll
yeah we're just talking about this
you'll just
lower the contrast in one image and then
the sweater's over there it's like what
would be better
let me let me actually let me put that
on the to-do list that's a good idea
i believe i believe two days ago we were
we were having our morning discussion
and we were reflecting on cowboy bebop
the live action series on netflix
and yeah isn't there there must be a way
that these companies can test something
before they spend lots and lots of money
making the final products
if only there's a way for us to do that
with sweatshirts to make sure people
like them before we order hundreds of
them
no there's no way to do that i'm sure of
it
raw intuition
yeah
which i don't have when it comes to
merch because we've only been doing
merch for a few years yeah
people might be wondering though
nico why are you in your yard and why am
i in my house is this 20 20
[Music]
no i'm i'm not in my house for any
anything covered related i am working
from home today
so
yeah i'm unfortunately i'm i'm covered
related
oh you're covered related i'm sorry to
hear it
i think i think wendy got the vid she
woke up this morning all sick and now
she's like i don't know
probably yeah it's probably better
tested yeah it's like everyone has like
the most mild cold
she threw she threw up this morning and
then that was kind of it nice getting
over it i don't know
everyone's
at the same time so it's weird yeah like
half the team's like i'm sick oh but
it's not covered another team's like i'm
sick and it is coveted we went to the
nobody we went to the but it is true and
she was like oh there's croup there's
flu b
there's covid
there's like
you know
lice there's
just pick it like whichever one you want
you can have it
yeah
yeah well that's what happens when you
have two kids in preschool
all right tell me about it
they're like wow you guys
petri dishes have you guys had to do
lice yet has that happened
oh yeah
yep wow
thankfully not yep it was uh actually it
wasn't that bad because we caught it
early and uh
and then we found the culprit we found
the suspect
of the source of it and it was coming
from one of eliza's friends at school
um and uh
yeah and then and then she had to go
home for like two weeks
um isn't that what does that say though
about that child's parents which is
that's well that's what i was thinking
because parents you you guys
catch it's it's like secondhand lice
it's like it's like by the way
your child's giving us likes
oh yeah and nobody else got that you
have to break it
yeah we went out and got the stuff for
it and we watched you know we watched
her head for like continuously for like
two weeks to make sure that it didn't
you know
that it went away properly
um and uh but then she kept going to
school and then this girl they hadn't
like
kicked her out to go home to get you
know cleaned up before she came back
[Laughter]
and uh yeah i don't know that's just
that's just what happens um but i i got
that feeling about the parent like what
are the what about the parents thought
because
the girl was kind of rude
and we had to tell eliza like hey you
don't have to play with her if she she
wasn't rude to eliza but she would be
rude if anybody else wanted to play with
eliza and we were like uh
you don't have to tell her who you can
play with you can just
and then
eliza told her that and then her
attitude got better and then the teacher
was like yeah eric i can't say her name
but yeah so and so has been
better since she's been playing with
eliza since when she came in so she's
better at playing but she's still
scratching her head we can't figure it
out
she's always thinking yeah
just constantly problem solving
she's a thinker
that's funny
that is funny
so it's
accurate stations
yeah
and background podcasts that awkward
delay that for some reason it's 2022 and
they haven't quite
decided to up the latency on wireless
systems yet
where's so it's like where's the 5g man
it's like when you're trying to walk
past somebody you both do the same move
at the same time
yeah
that's i miss that about wired phones
kids these days will never understand
yeah but seriously wired like you know
land lines where like the audio quality
was actually pretty solid
it was so good
it was so crisp you know and you could
hear everything in the background and
then you call your friend and you're
like hey is uh
johnny there
and you know his sister's like
john
there's no audio filtering so you can
hear everything from the other end
yep yeah yeah dude back in back in the
day when hold the music was actual hold
music because you could hear the music
um all right so do we want to talk about
the matrix or
or what i mean yeah just a little bit
but i don't even blow my nose
okay go play your nose yes
well i mean we've been fighting to talk
about it nico's been asking to talk
about this i know and i finally saw it
on friday
the rage hasn't started a little bit you
know i've like i've mourned my loss and
i'm ready to move on
so
yeah but for those of us who haven't
you know like what about what about us
let's just get right into the spoilers
let's just jump right into the sport
i'm down i'm down to go right into the
spoilers let's hear it spoiler alert
matrix for spoiler alert stop watching
if you care about the matrix four
spoilers and you haven't seen it yet
all right this is what this is what i'm
here for let's go okay look
let's start with the good stuff because
honestly there is some good stuff
and the good stuff is
it's super super super meta
the entire time
like the whole plot is
that
thomas anderson is a game designer
that has made this game called the
matrix
and it's a super super popular trilogy
and
the companies
the company which is warner brothers
which owns his game company
wants him
to make a fourth sequel to it
which i really like is great
it's a great premise it's great
it's awesome so the entire matrix isn't
actually an enslavement vehicle for the
whole of humanity no but it's but i
think it totally is it still is it's
just that like basically he's rebooted
himself or like
well technically not rebooted he died
and then the machines literally rebuilt
him
and i don't know why but the point is
that
they die he dies at the end of the
trilogy i think yeah yeah and then
and then they the machines like take his
dna and then
rebuild his body for some reason i
forgot i miss why but the point is that
he gets reinserted into the matrix
and as a video game designer and that's
his like persona his life you know like
he that's that's what he's led to
believe
got it
and so that's like and the and then the
trinity character from you know is the
same situation she gets rebuilt blah
blah but that made a story line
is is like
i'm like each time those meta scenes
were happening there's like tons of them
with like reintroducing morpheus as this
like a.i character
and i i mean
like yeah those things were they're
great they're super entertaining you
don't see it a lot it's like what
deadpool
is like the only other movie that
just like commits to breaking the fourth
wall all the time
it's and so you know it's
i don't know it like it it brings your
it lowers your barriers
really quickly when the movie is just is
like what's up it's the matrix hey what
up you know and you're like yeah okay
cool we this is a dialogue now
okay so
i don't know what do you think so
everyone still is
is beholden to the conditions of the
matrix
as established
yeah the matrix
yeah the computers are just trying to
trick neo into thinking
that all those memories you have were
just those those are just scenes in the
video game you made it's you're you're
just a game designer so
you know it's just it's their way of
like reestablishing him in this world
and i really like that part too like you
know the first 40 minutes of the movie i
feel like it was good storytelling and
it was the characters that i love and
it's like
fun twists on it and there's little
hints of things happening and the
mystery is there and like oh how's it
gonna break out what's gonna happen
yeah that and that was really nice
did they explain do you know do you have
clarity on why they reanimated him or
broke down his dna after he died because
didn't in his death didn't he destroy
the machine world isn't that there's
some like bs reason
because there was that yeah there's some
yes and the third one where he like you
know he goes all christ-like and then
like light shoots out of his body and
then like exactly yeah yeah yeah no
that's all still happened like once
again none nothing in the plot
i mean
the only reason they rebuilt him is for
this movie to exist
like there's no there wasn't there was
nothing i mean i like and then you build
him so that warner brothers can make a
well actually so so jake
that cynicism gets brought on full force
into the movie okay where it kind of
starts like being like oh what's your
guys's problem chill
all right so okay guys animate him right
so the captain of the ship that goes to
get neo and pull him back through her
life her name is bugs as in bugs bunny
which is a natural line from the movie
because she is a representation of
warner brothers going to dig up neo's
corpse so they can reanimate it to have
parade them around for a fourth matrix
okay
there's basically like there's layers
upon layers of that kind of cynicism
throughout the entire film right which
like a little bit of is fine is fine but
like at a certain point you're like guys
like quit attacking me for for liking
the matrix right right like
i'm here i showed up to watch your movie
chill
and they don't chill they never chill it
like it just keeps going it just keeps
going okay
yeah it just keeps going and going and
going to the point like that's fine in
like the first like like you do it right
away in the first couple minutes and
then you do it again like before the end
of the first act you do it a couple
times in the second act you know once or
twice yeah but by the third act it's
like okay let's
let's do the movie now i mean granted
the bugs bunny thing is like more i mean
for me anyways that's the thing i kind
of realized like after the fact it's not
attacking me as i'm watching it i'm just
like
oh she has like a white rabbit tattoo
and that's like bugs money you know and
like there's there is some
you know it does work together but
i mean well it sounds kind of quirky i
think i want to see it
it's it's it's
i almost said it's worth seeing i almost
said it
but it's almost it's kind of like not
this kind of like it has like two things
that that it does that
kind of put me over the edge of like see
here's the thing the movie's not a
neutral movie it's not like it's like oh
it's kind of boring or it's kind of
whatever no it's like
it's aggressive with its messaging and
just like that's what actually makes me
not like it is because of not because
it's aggressive because the message is
so much like a
like a screw you kind of message
i think i think it really just boils
down to
like there's a little bit a hypocrisy
like kind of like
they're just gonna reboot the matrix and
they're just gonna take it out and
milk it for all the money they can and
you're like okay
and you
took the job so you could write the
script and went out and then made the
movie the very thing that you're
criticizing
um
you know and i get it to a certain point
but like they clearly didn't care
about the movie like they didn't care
about the action i mean
maybe they cared about whoever was in
charge of making sure that you get a
good team to do it like or had enough
time didn't care
and the action scenes are like literally
like just the worst like bottom barrel
action i've ever seen
you said it was kind of like t like tv
drama i say i said netflix and and the
but the reason i say netflix is because
it's kind of like it's it's the idea of
like
every single time
there's an action scene in this movie
it's just like it's first off it always
happens in group settings so there's
always like five or six characters that
are in the middle of this action
sequence so like already the focus is
completely uh divided
okay and it usually just ends up being
like here's here's gonna be like 30 or
40 jump cuts to just like random
snippets of action happening around this
giant warehouse or this giant train or
this giant area you know it's like
and so it's just like he shoots bounce
he gets hit another person's shoes
another person gets and you're just like
whatever all right so so they're
fighting okay and then you sit back and
you wait for it to end and then the
story continues uh yeah and it was just
like
and the reason
i found that so offensive
was
for two reasons one
uh what nico was saying which is the
idea of the self-criticism
like that is one of the self-criticizing
parts of it where they like they have
characters
talking about rebooting this matrix and
they're like the action doesn't matter
no one really cares about the action
they just like the philosophical stuff
like forget you know it's like so
they're like already messing with your
head a little bit about like all right
so what what
what were we trying to do here but
ultimately you know you look at those
first three
matrix films i mean even though the
second and third ones
have their own problems
yeah when it comes to the way they
depict like action and these scenes they
are very clear with like what story
point is happening and then they're
really precise
with the filmmaking and the approach to
shooting it
and so
and then in this movie it's just kind of
like action scene
you know and just like
so yeah it's not it's just how much it
costs like it's not even about the
budget of the scenes like you know
granted like the second and third matrix
had huge huge action scenes that cost
millions and millions of dollars i'm not
really expecting them to do that for
this film but the first movie didn't
have that and still has exceptional
action scenes the thing is the action
scenes first movie has incredible action
scenes arguably the first movies action
scenes are more worthy than the later
ones because they brought in so much cgi
no the first movie the first movie is
one of the best i mean the matrix is one
of the best films of all time yeah yeah
you know that's also because they took
they had they had like hong kong
uh
uh like stunned choreographers and fight
choreographers and like robust training
for all the lead actors and it brought
it melded
two things that had never been in my
opinion properly melded before which is
the like michael bay level uh like
spectacle action sequence with like guns
and explosions and things like that like
the precision michael bay brings to it
with the precision that a jackie's chan
style
fight sequence has with it like in you'd
never gotten those that perfect blend
john woo almost nailed that with like
like hard target
and some of his like american films but
mission like never before had
like it took the two top like mission
possible to kind almost but even still
like not quite there like it was it was
basically it's you know realistically
there's only
there's only so many like actions genres
here but it took like the two
the two best ones and
managed to combine them in a
you know impactful way so yeah i don't
know it's just like like it
yeah even then every single shot was a
focused shot and every single beat was a
focus beat to tell a story partially
because the first matrix was also
storyboarded out literally shot for shot
for the entire film so it was already
every shot was a story before they even
shot the movie and it's so clear that
there's shots here they're just like
this might be cool let's get it and then
like the editor's like i'm just going to
cut to some of these shots
and you're like there's where's the
filmmaking like i there is filmmaking in
the matrix there's parts that are great
filmmaking and there's so many parts
that just don't have it
and once again it's just like where
where's the passion like
is this cynicism and i you know i wasn't
there i don't know but like is the
cynicism
so permeating everything in the matrix
that the teams just straight up didn't
care and they made this and just like
yeah and you just give it out like
you know why are you gonna do it at that
point yeah why even do it
why
yeah right
oh
hi
didn't see you there um hey i was just
looking for the best place to make an
explosive impact on your ability to get
the best stock assets on the internet
courtesy of today's sponsors storyblocks
don't you guys know come on storybox is
your one stop shop for all your asset
needs they've got high quality 4k b-roll
audio images after effects templates
motion graphics and uh say you want to
get into like a battle scene right and
you need like some footage of a desolate
european field so you can be like
when you can shoot out a rocket at your
uh bad guys in your film well guess what
you can do that with storybox right now
we use it all the time here at corridor
digital i'm always telling you this
there's a reason for that it's the best
place and the easiest place where we can
get stock assets i'm not gonna take this
thing fly it out to france into a field
and then you know attempt to shoot it
off so that i can have just one shot of
a world war two piece in my world war
three feature film no i'm not gonna do
that i'm gonna use story blocks and i'm
gonna use their unlimited all-access
plan which is gonna allow me to download
as much as i want whenever i want and
use it in whatever kind of project that
i want and then i'm going to just move
on with my life and you can get it right
now just go to storybox.com
corridorcast to get started that's
storybox.com
slash quarter cast all right i gotta go
do this
okay ready wish me luck
it's like there's a similar yeah but
like
at the very ending with uh with trinity
like when she
kind of wakes up and
you know realizes that she's in the
matrix
that suddenly takes his turn where it
suddenly becomes like
kind of about empowering her
and
you know like there's this whole quote
like can't you control your woman he's
like i like i i'm not in control of her
it's like that you know it's like it's
something that takes this weird kind of
like
you know i guess it's chauvinistic
you know
it's just it's just on the nose
yeah it's just way too on the nose and
then she's just like the part where like
so then she becomes the one
and like once again
having trinity as the one would have
been a great film i would have been down
for like the like the the curveball oh
you think neo's gonna wake up and he
takes the blue pill and you're like what
and so they have to go after trinity and
wake her up and say like that would have
been awesome and the movie's going out
there to say like you know trinity can
be like women can be these characters
trying to give me this character then
it's like then why didn't you make her
that character like if you're going to
criticize and you're going to do this
like you are the one in the power to do
something about it it's not somebody
else's job to now make a new movie
for trinity's main character you
literally should have made the movie
when you made the movie
you know it's just like yeah
you know it's like it's a company that
throws you
you yeah you have every right to yell
like you have every right to yell at
that kind of crap
because that's that is like the whole
that's that that's like the whole like
you know i don't i hate to use the like
the woke word but you know like that
that truly is the whole concept here of
of people saying they need more like
movies with this type of representation
they need like
and it's literally a moving a movie
saying they need this type of
representation while yeah while making
it
you know and you're like yeah rather
than like you could have just
changed the whole script that you were
using for this whole thing to like
do that to be the thing yeah just just
say that just say it at the end just
just say that the movie you know like
that's fine yeah um anyways
um
so there's lots of silly crap in this
movie and it's really dumb and um
like well maybe maybe i'll wait
maybe i'll wait till it's a rental
it just feels it's like you just watch
it and you it feels like someone had a
script and it was like oh there's some
cool ideas in the script and then when
it came time to shoot it
like dude from the first shot i was like
ugh like what is this crap like it looks
like
garbage
compared to like they're like they
recreate the first opening scene where
the like the cops bust in on trinity at
the computer like they recreate it and
you're watching it you're like oh like
what is this like crap crappy like
universal backlot like
you know what a scene and you're like
what is this kind of like some crappy
digital cameras with their crappy lenses
and you're just like
it was just like from the very first
shot i was like like slightly
embarrassed to be there
so you know they shot on alexa with
expensive lenses it's just like
they're sure but they forgot
yeah but they look like they did so many
stupid things wrong they did so many
stupid things they do all these like
slow motion sequences and then they
screw up their shutter speed so it's got
like the digital like
smearing where it's like you know in the
first movie you know when they do slow
motion first off they're shooting on
film so you know you're not talking
about the frame rate stuff you're not
talking about the low frame rate no i'm
not even talking about the i'm not
talking about like the janky like low
shutter speed like the 360 shutter
effects they're doing all over the place
i'm talking about like the tried and
true like here's a guy flying through
the air in slow motion or here's like a
slow motion punch or something you know
like like actual matrix slow motion
stuff
they i don't know like whoever the
cinematographer was like clearly forgot
like how to use the settings on the
camera or something but it like it looks
like
it looks like the junkiest digital video
slow motion like it looks
so amateur and yeah it's just i don't
know it's like i really hope it wasn't
the decision because
once again as a writer you can avoid
this problem by not writing action
scenes there's plenty of interesting
matrix related content out there that
has nothing to do with action the whole
thing and they could have done that
they could have skipped the action
yeah so the only good
action shots are the ones that are 100
cg in the film
yeah so
i think i think the moment the movie
broke my heart
was they mentioned like i think there's
a side of the like i wonder if you can
still dodge bullets
and it's like oh maybe he can still
what's going to happen and then they're
in this fight scene where the
merovingian shows up and like i guess
his fighter like i don't remember i
hated them
i thought the moment that mayor benjin
showed up in the original matrix sequel
i was like oh this movie lost me it's
definitely not the movie i wanted to see
so having him show up again in the
fourth movie it's just more of like
that's not what my heartbeat i was i was
like whatever i'll deal with it i
tolerated him in the other movies i'll
tolerate him here
and so then somebody somebody fires a
gun at neo and you know what the shot is
it's just a basic over-the-shoulder shot
of some guy holding the camera on you
know like because they're filming a
fight scene yeah you know second thought
and neil like can't read just like and
like looks over shoulder and then they
do the effect with the bullet in the
refractive discs and you're like that's
it that's your dodging bullet shot yeah
history it's cinema history and this is
your like ah you you throw it in
garbage you can't even like plan out
like one special angle for this like in
the first movie you planned out like 150
you planned out 150 special angles that
were locked off
all right you with that photo array and
then they are just like we're just going
to have it happen in the middle of this
dialogue scene
and then there they just just it's just
like shot is like i'm gonna shoot you
it's like no you're not
that's like that that was it
and you're just like you're like god
god
so that's when it broke my heart why i
was off the boat that was so bad
all right right okay i know and then
they recreate the subway fight
underground too it's so bad
when they go down under the ground and
they're like oh it's supposed to be like
the first one where he's fighting in the
subway tunnel and they're smashing
columns with their hands and it's just
like
the worst jump cuts and like the most
poorly choreographed crap and like
now i gotta see yeah i know but it's
like
it feels like it feels like i'm trying
to convince myself like that that i like
them oh like the bots the eyes changing
the matrix code i guess trying to
convince myself that it was kind of cool
and i really it's not cool matrix code
in your eye a matrix code who's like
it'll be cool if when they turn into
bots matrix code goes down their eyes
like what is
how does that thing fall into this world
i know i know like you know in the first
matrix each time there's like a person
there and an agent wants to get there so
he just goes
and he turns into the person and then
they run off and this one they're like
uh let's it's just we're just gonna make
it so that like anyone can turn into a
matrix person and we'll just have it so
that their eyes turn black and they get
little matrix codes in their eyes and so
just like
in within within the matrix this is
happening within the matrix yeah like
the agents don't need to take
the spots of the npcs anymore it's just
the npc's turn evil
and get matrix eyeballs
it's so sad
it's like those kind of creative
decisions just feel like
they put about two minutes they put
literally the amount of time it took sam
to say that is i feel like the amount of
creative effort they put into it like
but then there's other stuff in the
movie that's good
and just that's why it breaks my heart
so much you know
here's another thing that breaks my
heart okay so uh why doesn't lawrence
fisherman come back for this
uh so i don't know maybe he's too old
maybe he's too fat i don't know you know
there could be plenty of reasons but the
point is they recast him
and they recast him
instead of morpheus now it's a agent
like an evil agent with sunglasses that
kind of looks like morpheus already
and he gets interested in like what it
is like to be in real life
he you know he's like i wonder what's
outside the matrix and so he goes
outside
from once he says i'm interested in what
is outside the matrix the next time you
see him he's wearing morpheus clothes
and he says he's morpheus and you're
like whoa like
okay see you're morphing it's like and
no one questions it they explain that
no no they don't explain it at all like
they're it's literally they're just like
yeah this random ai wanted to be
morpheus anyways uh
and you're like wait and and so then the
entire movie he acts like morpheus
okay sure
and you're like he's like what's up i'm
morpheus is this kind of crazy it's a
callback you remember the scene with
morpheus that i used to be in i'm
morpheus and you're just like
this is interesting like i'm i'm
interested like
but they never explained like there's
never like a moment where the ai is like
the characters like look we we all know
i'm not morpheus but here's my thoughts
on who morpheus was as like maybe an
idea is why i'm like impersonating him
and you're like even just like the
tiniest like tiny character development
scenes are missing from this character
where they're just like
uh he's morpheus now anyways and you're
like
like
it's like it's like there's three
characters in the matrix it's there's
neo there's trinity and there's morpheus
and you're just like you lit you
literally just recast him
and like put zero work into like
explaining why
and it's so so infuriating
i mean like once again like all the
all this all the scenes with the
morphe's character are are like kind of
interesting scenes and they're kind of
cool but there's still that like plot
hole element eating away at you each
time you watch these scenes like
guys like you missed like one or two
important scenes i'm feeling it like why
is this just why why why why why did he
get recast like help just give me give
me that like justification so i can
forget thinking about it
i mean they even did that in the third
one when they recast or maybe it was the
second one then they recast uh the
oracle
yeah
the actress passed away and like you
know it was the same character so it's
like it's a little weird to like go too
heavy into it outside like they did a
brief acknowledging whereas this was
like i thought that was good i thought
the way that they did it in the second
one was good where they just they simply
say like there's one line that she says
which is like
i'm not i got it i don't know what yeah
it was something like that but it was
like oh yeah that makes sense she's a
program yeah
this one is just like here's here's
here's an evil agent that looks just
like
like a young lawrence fishburn
and he just wants to be morpheus and
you're like is it because you look like
like
is that literally just legends like at
home in his bathrooms like when agents
go to their apartments and like take
shot what no they're computer programs
they don't have lives outside of being
agents
yeah and it's not like yeah it's like
they can't take a red pill or anything
you know like like i don't know i don't
know
oh my god it's so silly it's so silly it
just makes no sense yeah
the agents have work hours
and also by the way
yeah they have workouts no but they live
npc lives apparently which makes no
sense either because the agents in the
first one are like literally just an
enforcement protocol to make sure that
the matrix keeps running it's not like
they need to blend in with society
they're just like cops that like that
constantly go around fixing issues and
they don't need to sleep
they don't need a personal life they
don't need that you know like they're
like just they're literally bots you
know
so
so then he's like he's at his mirror
he's like he's just shaved and he's like
what up what is the matrix and you're
like
what like who is this like what are
these changes say that does he
basically i don't can't remember the
exact dialogue okay
oh man that's amazing the movie has like
philosophical problems it has structural
problems it has like cinematography
problems and then there's just like they
had jada pinkett smith come back to play
like her same character she's now like
the queen of like the human underworld
and they put so much makeup on her that
she is unrecognizable as jada pink and
smith like i literally did not know who
i was looking at until i i am db'd like
i think that's jada pingas what
no no you mean you'd
like for me each the character would
you didn't recognize her until they
showed you the old footage of the movie
right
which they constantly do they're just
like constantly cutting back to the
first movies as if like
oh the movie's a video game but we won't
recreate it in a video game engine we'll
just show you frames in the movie and
we'll just assume that everybody's cool
with suspending their disbelief and
weirdly enough i kind of was but like
now that i don't like the rest of the
movie it's just like wait you're just
showing me clips from a movie a movie i
saw 20 years i know he was telling me
it's a video game and i'm just buying it
i know
you tell me i know i know like the scene
where they like try and break them out
and they have the footage on they were
like we thought we'd show you footage of
your own game to get you uh like more
acclimated to like breaking out of the
matrix or to make you feel more
comfortable here it's like no that's
that's the movie
it's like i mean they could have at
least done like enter the matrix or some
crap like that and like had it be like
like actually the video game matrix that
was that was out which would have been
also that would have earned so many
points it would have been hilarious
you know to think it was like keanu
reeves made the enter the matrix game
[Laughter]
like i'm like here we go like yeah like
if you already don't give a [ __ ] why not
just do that it's so much more fun
are there characters in
there regular civilians who are living
in the matrix unaware that it's the
matrix who are playing the matrix video
game
yes there's people who play yeah they're
they they reference that a lot that like
people in the matrix have played this
game called the matrix
okay
um
yeah it's it's a thing
oh man
oh by the way i'm sorry this is a small
one but this one was one of my favorites
as far as like really dumb things which
is like
so they go through this huge action
scene they're trying to break
neo out of the matrix they're trying to
like get him out of there
and
boom they finally do it he wakes up he's
in his pod
and two robots like pick him up
and fly him out of
the main
like machine area it's like he wakes up
two machines go like oh it's him he's
awake and they pick him up and they just
fly him away
and then he gets there and he's like oh
what's happening
oh we have to get trinity and they're
like nah can't
like
why it's like we can't we're we're not
allowed to go back now
it's like what
like what to the reason and then that
becomes the entire plot of the movie
the machines
pick up neo and bring them out of the
matrix and they leave trinity by the way
it's like it's a giant massive like
hundreds of square meters sized mega
chamber and the only two people in it
are neo and trinity they send some
robots in to pick up neo and they leave
after this apparently it was really hard
to do that
but then now they're like oh now we need
trinity too but we can't do that it's
impossible to go back it's like
what
it's like dude why didn't you just get
her
when you were there
robots want to go back and take her no
no like all the humans and crap you know
it's like
it's just like this stupid thing you
watch these robots go like um we're just
gonna get neo bye and then they leave
and you're like okay trinity's that that
that was true an idiot okay whatever
don't worry about it you know
and then they get back to the ship and
they're like oh we should
if you don't take the red pill then you
like it breaks your mind when you get
pulled out of the matrix i guess so but
they figured it out it's like a usb end
of the move right click on it you need
to say safe to eject before you pull the
safe to each other
but in the movie they say the pills do
nothing
they're just they're just like metaphors
they say that in the fourth one
yeah they said they said the pills are
just metaphors
wow
anyways um and that really ticked me off
because it was just like one of those
dumb like hey there's neo and trinity ah
okay trinity later and then they leave
and they're like oh whoops
darn it forgot anything
we screw that up we forgot to get the
other important person
she's like welcome back neo you're going
to jail and you're like why what is this
i know it was it's like the classic
like [ __ ] plot there like it's like the
hero and savior of humanity that made
humans and machines gain everlasting
like truths and then they're like you're
in jail neo because
and you who the person you you girl who
saved him
you don't get to fly your spaceship
anymore you're punished and it's like
just like what like
sorry sorry like i'm sorry i saved god
i literally i went to heaven god was in
trouble and i saved him and then you're
like
no i didn't say you could save him so
you're in trouble and you're like just
shut up it's like shut get out of here i
don't give a [ __ ] about the real world
i don't give a [ __ ] about real world
politics i don't care about your stupid
underground freaking like rave chamber
i don't give a crap about any of this
stuff
there's a moment where they they show
for a brief moment the machine civil war
apparently after neo dies some machines
are like maybe we shouldn't be so evil
and other computers like no this is
definitely why we should be and they had
a war and there's like one shot of it
you're like whoa that's cool
and that's oh yeah that was that was an
awesome shot and i remember specifically
seeing that shot of going like wow look
at look at how like little animation
was put into this shot it's like a great
frame it's like practically like a
painting
and you're looking at it you're like wow
that's really cool
and then it cuts and you're like
that's nope no
you think you'll really like the scene
where they put neo in jail it's like ah
not really entertained by that
it doesn't really help me why did they
put him in jail
because it's like baby he's like five
year olds writing it
because he would start fights
yeah if like if neo is here he's gonna
try to break everybody out of the matrix
again and we have a true machines now
and like it's like we finally have peace
we finally have peace and neo threatens
world peace and you're like
are you
he [ __ ]
made the world peace
like like literally without neo without
proving to the machines that humans had
the willpower to break out of that
artificial creation called the matrix
humans would never have had the leverage
to create a truce in the first place
like
i'm sorry it's just no that makes sense
man
these are the kind about the matrix
right now stars that you are opening up
we were going to be like a five minute
segment this is the entire podcast i'm
so glad we decided to talk about the
matrix this is like really important
this is really important stuff
that's really important
it's really important that people here
and like let me let me like let me like
put this out there too it's like these
aren't like these aren't like
afterthoughts of the movie where you get
at it and go thinking about it you're
like
huh wait a second that was weird and
you're like these are the things you're
saying in your head as you're watching
the movie
yeah like it's it's it's
it's that
clumsy with the storytelling
yeah interesting there's things like
you see the real world and all the
humans in their pods and you're like oh
my goodness it's been so long since i've
seen a movie with this art direction and
like it's been so long since i seen
movies build worlds like this that
aren't like superhero worlds where like
you get cool sci-fi weird like grotesque
geiger-esque like
what like what happened to all my
adventures in like human artistry that
films used to have i miss this stuff
it's i'm so nice to see you again and
like and that's the thing again as the
movie pulls these moments out we're just
like all right i used i loved all this
stuff i haven't seen it in decades like
because that part of cinema died
it's so nice to see it again and it's
like exactly
and
those moments are some of the best
as i was saying like just just like that
like those those shots are they're
incredible like yeah they happen to also
be the
like all those shots happen to also be
the 100 cg shots as well
like
like the
yeah every time the ships are flying
through the tunnels you're seeing the
pods you're in these like like even in
the action scenes like the coolest
stunts are done by digital performers
and um
like they
they
are so like they come as such huge like
breaths of fresh air as you're watching
it and it was yeah
i don't know
so it's so it it's populated with
like this the sprinkles are excellent on
top of that cupcake but
yeah the cupcake itself
that's a cupcake it's a little little
stale
cupcake has like something put like
razors in the cupcake specifically
despite you
it's not like it's a bad cupcake like
the dough like it tastes good just
somebody put things in it to hurt you
that's what this movie is like
it's not a bad movie
it's a mean movie the movie was mean to
me
yeah
oh that's i've never heard anyone
describe a movie that way
never
but the movie is there the movie is
there to spite you for watching it
if i ever get so and taken towards my
audience you need to like you need to
cut me off i'll dial you back don't
worry
we'll dial you back
it was sweet how they used nanobots to
bring the ai characters into real life
though
that was sweet i was totally downfield
i'm like yeah that's sweet
that's cool
it was sweet when people were jumping
out of buildings to try to air bomb them
on their motorcycle with their corpses
that was sweet
that was sweet too
that was sweet
you know oh man
you know it wasn't sweet as the last
shot where they're flying away and they
are very clearly on wires awkwardly
hanging there well
he was like
oh i can't i'm not flying he's just
hanging all right
yeah that's what i want so what happens
what happens in the end
they fly like jump off the rooftop
uh trinity flies
and she holds neo's arm but it is very
clearly she's on wires and he's on wires
and they fly away and then there's a
cover of the rage against the machine
song just an awful cover in my opinion
oh because they couldn't
they couldn't there's even like
controversy with this band where there's
like the lead singer oh my god you're
right on the fans face which is like
that comes from
machine cover starts and you're like oh
this is the band that peed on the guy
[Music]
literally
yeah like literally that is so so funny
like that
that is true that is like jake there you
go that what is the last shot of the
movie
obviously it's the credits it's the
credit sequence
uh but no you can be right you go to
twitter to see afterwards yeah no if you
type in the band yo no i remember seeing
that too that was hilarious
wow you're right so yeah your last
thought is oh hmm
i'm watching i'm imagining
someone getting
peed on
that that is that is that is the like
the lasting image you get
like no no this is this is true
no it's it's a bra
no it's a brass cover band that did a
cover of the the theme song that the
ending credit song right which was
originally raging against the machine
uh so yeah anyways uh it's really
honestly i mean honestly perfect
metaphor it's a perfect metaphor
and honestly we after we talk about if
we talk about this anymore like
that that's it that's like the end of
this conversation right here
that's it that's it effectively
it's the same as going to a concert
and having the band pee on you
to spite you for attending the concert
yep yes that's exactly what this movie
is like
through that
attitude
i hate it
they should have done better
but seriously i only got that attitude
my only thought was
was that a conscious choice or not did
they because like once again
like this
this way man
actually you're probably right maybe it
was a conscious choice it could have
been a conscious choice and the reason i
say that is because i think that didn't
happen like a few months ago
you know like we're talking about three
months which is like i think that's
enough time to pivot and swap out that
song
yep
wow or it's like why not pick a new song
yeah
it because because because because it
really just gives me those like
freaking star wars vibes of like ah
okay i get it
sounds very manic
like that's just like sounds kind of
manic
you know everything this man these days
these days filmmaking you know they're
just in it for the money like star wars
right they like they had the thought the
first thought with the new star wars
films was not
i have a cool idea for a movie the first
thought of the new star wars films was
how can we make more money off of star
wars let's go and figure out a story to
write and it was like yeah that's the
attitude from yeah to an extent it's
like yeah a little bit and it kind of is
and it kind of sucks but the reality is
that's always been the attitude in films
people didn't make the first matrix like
just because they had a cool idea they
also wanted to make money
you know it's like that's always been
part of these so just like act like it's
a new revelation right now traditionally
you try to go through a movie that's
good like a story that's good is ideally
the leading principle for why it makes
money
yes
100
but still
if somebody's like hey you have two
years to make a film like based on star
wars we want to make some money i'm i'm
still going to try to make the best dang
movie i can make because that's awesome
like great you got two years to make the
movie go for it you know like you should
be excited you should be passionate
right so yeah yeah
all right i'm sorry i did that to you
i'm sorry i did it to you both
it's fine it's f it's fine i feel like i
have the right mentality to go into
watching it now though
it helped it helped watching those clips
you know on react ahead of time because
it definitely helped like
it it brought my expectations down
just enough to the point where i wasn't
like angry
while watching it
right
but yeah
oh it's not here yet
yeah missy it's missing that the
delivery man is going to come with it
and you'll be
very excited here
yeah
this could be so cool
yes do you guys want to hear a totally
different story about something totally
entirely unrelated
sure yeah okay so um
the other night uh
i heard i got a dog i told you about
that
mm-hmm um and uh so you got this dog
she was outside barking like bark just
really you know
so i go out there and i'm like what what
are you barking at um
and i grab a flashlight it's dark out uh
i go out there
and she's got this possum
cornered against a rock and the possum
is making this like horrible screeching
sound which is it's kind of the noise
they make when they're
in danger
and uh then she sees me walking up
towards her because i'm gonna try to i
don't want the possum to bite her so i'm
gonna try to break this up right like
you know i'm gonna try to get her away
from it
and as i as i'm about to do this
she goes for its neck
oh wow
and and like
gets it right and and kills it
um
and so now i'm like
oh okay
um
so
i'm looking at i look at it and i find
out
like upon looking at it after it had
died that she had she must have gotten
it on the leg first
because its leg was all broken and like
mangled out to the side so i think
that's why it hadn't run away
but um
i didn't really want this like animal to
go to waste so
i did my first pelt
oh wow yeah um and uh i didn't had no
idea deal what i was doing but i watched
a few youtube videos and i actually got
a pretty decent um pelt off of this
possum
so yeah um i think i'm gonna hang it in
my garage or something and then eliza
really wants to turn it into a hat for
my cat but that might be a little
you know a little weird
but uh it was super interesting man like
um i'd never done anything like that
before and uh it was just
you know like the
just the process of it and like the body
is actually really simple
when it comes to like
how how it's
it's just all these parts that are like
mashed together and you know you you
look at like an animal
and you're like well i don't know what's
in there
but
you know or where it is
i i sure i'm sure doctors do you know
i'm sure physicians like see that as
when they when they look at a person or
or an animal but um
yeah i don't know i thought it was
interesting it was an interesting
experiment i mean i remember going deer
hunting and like you know seeing a deer
get gutted for the first time and it's
like
like a little slice and blood all the
guts falling like wait
it's that easy right like
all it just all falls out
because
the trachea
connects you know goes through all the
guts
and then that goes out through you know
obviously the the anus
you just you just have to like
cut it in those spots
and then remove it from
the way that the where it connects with
fat tissue to the skin and to the rest
of the
yeah
but that was that was those were the
videos that i was watching because i was
you know i'm gonna go hunting and i was
like people are gonna be listening to
this podcast and they're gonna be like
what the heck
right like look at that
all right you like hamburgers
well you're going to listen to us talk
about gutting animals a little bit all
right yes it's the only thing and the
matrix we go 50 minutes to the matrix
and then we go five minutes on that this
is the only way to cool down from
talking about the matrix it was
interesting i feel like i'll be better
at it next time um and i'm glad that the
animal didn't go completely to waste so
yeah that's good
and sam i think if you're talking we
can't hear you
you might be muted
so we'll just yeah we'll just keep going
until he comes back
he's making a okay hand sign
okay
maybe he can hear us maybe not
um
yeah
man i don't i don't have anything else
to talk about now we're done talking
about the matrix frankly yeah
it's tight it's tiring man
yeah it is like those are real emotions
you guys got the real nico in this
podcast yep you know what maybe can you
hear me
anyways so i have a child trying to
break in here it's kind of crazy right
now
that's what i'm saying it's okay and
also this mic was recording
everything i was saying still um okay
but yeah no talking about yeah
dismembering animals great way to cool
down from the matrix obviously
yeah it was it was a great landing pad
there right just like kind of let's move
it away we're getting peed on
we're getting peed on and then we dry
off and then we go hunting that's right
yeah
all right well hey thanks for uh
breaking it down for me i'm excited to
um i'm gonna see it eventually anyways
but i'll go in with the mentality that
i'm about to be urinated on and i think
that'll help
yeah that'll help so you know bring an
umbrella
okay all right and then change your
clothes and change your clothes all
right
drink some beers you'll have a good time
okay
group group watch
group watch
all right well that was fun it's good
hanging out with you guys this afternoon
yeah
yeah yeah and as always thanks for
listening to the corridor cast and uh
who knows maybe next time we'll talk
about sausages and
felt hats
let's do a like a live sausage
uh
party
where we make sausages
and then we'll just talk about it
for a podcast perfect all right
all right
all right all right guys see you later
see you later all right until next time